do elizabeth and lucas say i love you to
each other in season nine they're
magical words aren't they
plenty of drama plenty of stakes
suspense and comedy it's something new
it's a bit of a breath of fresh air we
boldly go where wayne calls the heart
has not gone before there's one moment
that's gonna go down in when calls the
heart history there are two really big
moments we're kind of taking an abrupt
turn and life is gonna throw us some
curveballs you'll always be on the edge
of your seat to cut some capacity when
you're watching this everybody's going
to be tested it's going to be pushed to
the limit seeing this man you love with
this child that you love so much it
probably gets the ovaries going i would
think
can i say that
you are my adventure
you are my passion
[Music]
now that we're in season nine where do
we find elizabeth and lucas on the the
path to their budding romance we see
that they have progressed in their
relationship we're getting to explore
more of what that relationship is in a
family dynamic with little jack and what
that relationship is like in their
private more intimate moments together
fueled by care and respect and
understanding but also a fair amount of
passion they're not holding back i'll
say that we don't want them to hold back
because some of my favorite moments on
the show over the years have been those
beautiful romantic gestures are those
gonna continue in season nine well of
course i mean it's a very lucas bouchard
move to do these grand romantic gestures
but actually without spoiling too much
elizabeth and lucas do share a few
conversations about how
that isn't the only way to show
your love for your partner and that
actually the simple little things and
the little moments can mean just as much
it is very much of a honeymoon stage off
the beginning for lucas and elizabeth
but i think
another theme that is integral to this
season is communication perhaps small
gestures are at times more meaningful
than large gestures so we'll see them
try and make their way through that
making some mistakes along the way but
uh hopefully ultimately learning to be
cohesive together do elizabeth and lucas
say i love you to each other in season
nine they're magical words aren't they
and how do i tease this i think it would
be a good thing if that happened i think
they're in love the l word uh they do
like each other so yes they express that
well erin you know what happens when two
people are in love sometimes that
results in a proposal oh tell me more i
know you obviously can't reveal whether
or not that that happens but you know is
it fair to say that they're on the track
towards that this is the same ring that
i've been wearing since season one i
took it off temporarily when i was
wearing the engagement ring and wedding
band from jack rest his character's soul
and it's back so uh maybe something will
replace it on my left hand this season
we will see 100 lucas is known from the
start that elizabeth is different to him
and is the person that he wants to spend
his life with but as far as an actual
proposal
i don't know
okay we'll stay tuned i think one of the
things that fans are really excited to
see is lucas's growing and developing
bond with elizabeth's son little jack so
i'm curious have you been filming with
little jack this season there is so much
filming with little jack this season and
i'm i'm
i'm very excited to see how
the fans react to that dynamic there is
activities
dinner
schemes
plots games yeah there's a there's a ton
i think i want to be a dad now lucas and
little jack just get along so well i
think for elizabeth it's just like a
heart melt every time she sees them
together she's falling deeper and deeper
in love with him because he's not just
like
you know this dudley guy who owns the
saloon he's the studly guy who owns the
saloon and is like great with her son do
you think spending all this time with
little jack and really bonding together
do you think that that's giving lucas a
little bit of the itch to maybe expand
the family even further someday um
i think that of course has to be
something on lucas's mind but i also
just want to
point out that his
relationship with jack and and
experiencing that dynamic is i think
very very fulfilling not to
disregard
jack's character and his thornton at all
but
lucas feels a desire and a
responsibility to want to step up and be
a father figure to jack i just have to
you know imagine that seeing this man
you love with this child that you love
so much you just you know your heart
explodes into a million pieces yes it
probably gets the ovaries going i would
think can i say that
i want to just like rip the band-aid
right off elizabeth and lucas are
together ow
my boy nathan how is he doing we don't
just kind of pick up like he's all
better
but without a doubt he you know
elizabeth's happiness has always been
you know his main focus he comes to
terms with how happy she is and he
learns to accept it and uh and you know
it brings in a very interesting
dichotomy to lucas and nathan who
you know might have butted heads in the
past but he does see what a good guy
lucas is how would you describe like the
terms that nathan is on with elizabeth
and also with lucas friendly terms for
sure with with uh elizabeth and lucas if
it wasn't a love triangle there was
there's something that always connected
those characters to be together and you
know and drama ensues when they're
together so i think it's it's a great
thing when we see the three of them
together i think the big question on my
mind
is will nathan find love or romance
in season nine nathan finding romance
and love will happen in season nine
whether
he jumps on it or whether that
opportunity you know balloons into
something
that can be called a relationship is yet
you know yet to be determined you got it
you got to watch to find out
but
that opportunity
does come into nathan's life yeah do you
want to see him with somebody we already
know in hope valley or do you think he
should possibly be with a brand new
character there's a lot of fans who
really enjoyed the scene between nathan
and faith
in the season eight finale
at the end of season
eight
those two
could really get on the same wavelength
understood each other you know so i mean
for them to both be at that spot at the
end definitely puts them in in a new
area moving into season nine you know
and kind of a friendship would blossom
out of that and an understanding and we
do see that kind of
grow for sure i think if nathan connects
with you know with the person whether
it's somebody new or somebody
that's been in the town for a while
there are new people that come into the
town so that that could be a possibility
it could be anybody that makes me so
happy i can't wait to find out who it is
well nathan's true love is his dog i
mean ali is the one that he cares about
the most there's some very sweet moments
between the two of them you know this
season as that relationship grows and
you know ally
growing up too that's it's a big thing
nathan really doesn't have a kind of
female presence in his life to help out
when those questions get at you know
when a young woman starts asking
questions that the father figure is like
i don't know the answer to this and you
know we we start to venture in that
territory a little bit uh throughout the
season which is i think you know super
funny and fun there's a really
really sweet scene kind of in the middle
of the season between the two of them
erin was even telling me she's like this
is a really really great scene this is
gonna be a favorite scene for sure this
is a very like
like it'll make you like you know clutch
your pearls or whatever like
the question and the notion of lee and
rosemary becoming parents it's been
something that's been on the table for
now quite a few seasons yep i know you
can't tell us if they're officially
becoming mom and dad but will we get an
answer about
the future of their family planning
in season nine for better or for worse i
think that after this season fans will
not need to ask that question anymore i
think we have finally found a way to
resolve
anybody
belaboring that question i think we're
gonna address it it's all i've heard
about for the last i don't know three
maybe even four seasons i feel like this
season we see more resolution on that
journey than ever and and i'm just i'm
so pleased with how that that story is
told this season and it's it's
complicated it's complicated and it's
it's nuanced and it's not easy it's not
easy and i'm just so excited for fans to
go on the ride with us let's say
hypothetically lee and rosemary do
become parents in season nine why do you
think now is the right time for them to
expand their family why it's more
impactful now
is because i think it's when people
finally give up hope that they tend to
you know you give up on things and if
you do
give up on things you might miss that
one in a million chance you know you can
never
ever give up on something that's
important was that
you and pascal politely knocking on john
tinker's door saying hey we need some
resolution here regardless of what the
outcome is we gotta like address it here
there was nothing polite about knocking
on the door this is a story line that
the fans have wanted but but almost
more than that pascal and i have wanted
resolution and i'll give pascal credit
where credit is due she really
spearheaded this year she was not going
to let it go
she was determined to get an answer and
uh it's because of her tenacity that we
got it and the fans will get it too i
really felt very strongly that there was
a certain story that should be told and
fortunately uh our writers were really
receptive to hearing that conversation
and you know john tinker and i we we sat
down a number of times over the phone
over zoom over face time uh kind of
plotting it out and and
mapping out the storyline of how what
was the most respectful way of telling
this story and we touch base throughout
the season of how to how to go forward
and i'm really happy that we did because
i i really believe in this storyline
very strongly we have flip-flopped a
little bit throughout the years are you
team adoption or team pregnancy i've
always been team baby so give them a
child any way that you want i just have
always thought they needed to have a
baby a baby in their life yeah adoption
or pregnancy can i pick both i'd like a
scoop of each please if are the culture
is going to welcome multiple children
this season because i'd be down i'm not
saying anything but wouldn't that be
something we got to meet the entire
canfield family in season eight where do
we find joseph in season nine yeah
joseph is very well established in the
community at this point he is the pastor
so you get to hear me do some sermons
he's running around counseling people
he's making sure that everybody's all
right there's a caution to doing that if
you spend a lot of time
dealing with other people you can kind
of miss what's going on in your own home
and so that's that's joseph's big big
lesson for this season there's lots of
conversations between joseph and cooper
we learn a lot more about cooper
and how he handles
certain subject matters certain topics
what kind of a space is cooper in in
season nine well uh young master elias
gets to kind of flex his muscles a
little bit in the in this season he's
getting a little older getting a little
more brazen which is interesting because
it couldn't be further from elias in
real life he's super sweet super easy
going but cooper starts to kind of push
the boundaries and test the limits he's
in a rebellious stage but what what i
like about this story is it's not just
because you know hit a certain age it's
not just because hormones are shifting
or changing i don't know it goes back to
his love for his family he questions a
lot of things his faith included his
questions if cooper was played by
another little actor it'd be amazing to
watch but that's my son we have
conversations about everything before we
do it
and it's really really cool to watch i'm
just i'm so proud of them what can you
tell me about angela's trajectory this
season angela
is
spreading her wings the thing that i
abs i love about
angela and about watching my daughter
vienna play angela is that angela
doesn't let her blindness define her
it's the independence that she's pushing
for and it's well deserved and we have
to let go we have to let go a little bit
when i know that minnie especially is
very protective of her baby girl now
that angela is in school like you said
she's going to be a little bit more
independent
how are joseph and minnie going to
handle that the roles have kind of
switched because in season eight it was
really joseph that was like no no let
her go she has to she has to learn and
in season nine it's really minnie who's
like let her go she has to you gotta let
her go past this point we got to see
minnie really thrive working in the cafe
last season
what are we gonna see minnie tackle in
season nine she's really pushing joseph
to
think of different things to do to take
care of the family to take the family to
another level all while chasing her
passion oh well yeah all while chasing
her her passion she the cafe becomes a a
huge centerpiece of mini storyline we
watched the season eight finale and
there was that kind of like
soul-crushing moment part of me thought
when the stage pulled away that carson
would be there
where does team infirmary stand when we
pick up in season nine faith is still
very much dealing with and digesting
that sort of i want to call it a bit of
a fizzle out between uh faith and carson
and now that she's working alone trying
to realize all of the dreams at the
infirmary by herself it really makes her
think back to carson and there are some
moments where she very much is forced to
deal with that relationship so by no
means is it finished uh she still has a
lot to contend with okay so we have not
seen the last of faith in carson there
are still loose ends that need to be
tied up she definitely has a little bit
of a broken heart that needs mending so
you'll see faith confronting that this
season in a really honest way can you
define their relationship status are
they together are they not together uh i
mean i want to give you the classic
friends response they were on a break
[Laughter]
we were on a break
i want to call it a permanent break
they're they're chasing their own dreams
right now i don't know what that means
for the future but at the moment they're
focusing on themselves are we going to
get any carson cameos this season
he is mentioned so you'll have to wait
and see do you want to see faith
explore romance in season 9 or do you
want to see her more focused on her
career
i would really love
for faith to find her footing to really
ground herself in hope valley as she is
right now i think that's so important
before entering into any type of new
dynamic or relationship eventually i
would love to see this character happy
she works so hard she bottles so much up
and i would just love to see her free
and and allowing herself to express
herself the way that she she deserves to
express herself the scene between faith
and nathan when they're together at the
end of season eight a lot of fans like
the idea of them maybe sort of bubbling
up a romance what do you think about
that i think that was actually one of my
favorite scenes from season eight it was
just a really simple honest
moment between two broken-hearted people
whose lives deviated from the direction
that they were expecting them to go in i
think that nathan and faith do share a
lot of things in common they're people
who service their communities they put
others before themselves and their own
needs time and time again and i think
that was a really special check-in and
uh
and yeah yeah i don't know i don't know
[Music]